Hachi Machi middle class famous tour
update Kippy oh we got a couple alerts
going out straighten them out a little
bit Yeah guys so uh we're coming to
Seattle and Portland unfortunately
Seattle is sold out so if you want
tickets you're gonna have to come see us
in Portland then we're going to Kansas
City Springfield St Louis Nashville in
the Philadelphia that show sold out
already three months ahead of time we
added a second Show tickets are on sale
right now then we're going up to
Providence Rhode Island that's going to
sell out in Boston there's low ticket
alert so get those tickets now we'd love
to see you do it welcome so another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage
our favorite comedians and find out that
you're to be classy or you're just a big
old piece of trash trash I'm your
hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she's upstairs getting
ready for the fall doing a little
pickling okay over cigarettes
we gotta start taking submissions on
these
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table technically I got a giggle at
him so it counts as a win he's the CEO
of are you garbage he's International
businessman he's the prince of Park
Avenue but always the king of the
boardwalk give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan Hey everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate if
you subscribe over there on iTunes even
though I don't [ __ ] mean anything no
more yes it does then you go over there
to
www.youtube.com are you garbage check it
out because I think those numbers are up
cooking uh and then obviously shout out
to Al Gore for creating the internet
shout out to Sam yam and Jack Conte for
creating the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com
you get episodes of hard feel you get
the live stream you get bonus content
we're coming out the [ __ ] Wazoo with
bonus content yeah overstuffed over
stuffed double stuff bonus content like
those videos you watch
um we're just dropping it should be be
soon or it should be out right now the
camping trip we just did meet T-Bone and
new guy Luke went up there and the
Catskills got an RV and boy do we have a
good time full long video on the patreon
right now check it out I don't give any
spoilers but I fought a grizzly
is that a gay bar but still
nice Cruiser extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good he works the
ones and twos threes and fours crosses
the t's he dots the eyes he spins all
the hits does time and temperature
around the eighths give it up for Tebow
McMuffin Toby McMullen what's up dudes
what up T-Bone you have a present for us
from what I understand oh yes indeed we
have a beautiful piece uh submitted it's
a collaboration between a bunch of
people we we hold near and dear to our
hearts frame of mind art uh really who
put this can in my hand and some other
folks dabbled really it's an unboxing
video it sure is and it's like Mr Beast
I haven't seen I haven't seen it yet
what's inside but in person but it's
pretty dope from the photos okay and
they did all this behind our backs I
don't know I don't know I don't like
that yeah I don't like people plotting
on me plus this isn't going to be a
smooth opening
it's taped up like a nuclear football I
know what the [ __ ] I got a hot car I got
a hot cup of joe over here yeah you'll
be you'll be editing around this
all right fully uh man the uh hey I got
a Dr Pepper over here what are you
talking about I'm busy unfolly you're
you're on audio here I'm gonna
okay yeah you're a professional vamper
all right
slicing it over you stink it dizzy
okay all right all right if it's a
kitten I'm gonna be very upset it's
pretty [ __ ] sweet if I do say so
myself I hope we hate it to be honest
with you
is this a new set piece is that what
you're envisioning I don't know we'll
see we'll see how it checks out like I
said I haven't seen it in person
okay all right I saw a little piece
all right
Hachi Machi you open out like a dad
putting a bike together on Christmas man
[ __ ] Ikea Jesus Christ
pretty [ __ ] sweet
all right all right listen I [ __ ] on you
for packaging it but you did a pretty
[ __ ] great job
oh my God that's beautiful it's so sick
Dude Perfect what the [ __ ] that's
awesome it's even sicker than I thought
it would be where's that going in the
middle I don't know that's [ __ ] sweet
yeah that's beautiful ah shout out to
cornbread Customs Han and Tony we
appreciate it baby uh we were in contact
with who put this candy man he reached
out and organized this amazing
opportunity to work with the graphic
designer uh logo Trevin from frame of
mind art on Instagram holy [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] sweet guys thank you so [ __ ]
beautiful man that's great and for the
audio listeners it's a giant badass
ayg sign with a trash can with a
Mountain Dew bottle a carton of Bernie
some spray cheese couple past two bills
a couple of Red Cups the whole nine
yards and I will be selling this to the
highest bidder
get my eBay account going
awesome thank you reset my password
fellas thank you so much T-Bone you put
this together I didn't do [ __ ] they DM
me I said don't tell the bosses
that's very nice man thank you guys so
much it's [ __ ] beautiful not gonna be
worried people are plotting against me
their setup's going on probably a
microphone in that thing I don't trust
it oh yeah oh okay we're scanning this
thing for bugs for sure dude
Jesus Christ you said that like a dude
on the boulevard
Hachi Machi that's fantastic we gotta
figure out where to put that maybe that
goes there I was thinking I know I don't
want to spice it up a bit we'll figure
it out yeah it's very cool man [ __ ] I
don't know if the wood panel can hold
that thing that thing's pretty [ __ ]
heavy bike what's the shipping on that
had to be like three grand a couple of
sinkers but they just sent that to us
that's correct oh it's so funny that's
awesome guys you guys are the [ __ ]
best you're the [ __ ] absolute best
look at this look at this family gotta
love it baby I love it yeah that's
beautiful that's honestly so much it's
great all right I have a question for
you fellas I'm listening uh a little bit
a little something from New Guy Luke NGL
and shout out to new guy Luke NGL slid
this one my way I said run up the
flagpole what do you think is the better
deal the dollar slice or the dollar can
of Arizona
dollar slice yeah what do you mean
dollar slice all the way yeah food food
Trump's beverage always beverage just
fills you up but for what you get free
water cup over there too the best value
is going to Chipotle ask for a watercolm
Philadelphia with Diet Coke and leave
that's the best value all right if we're
doing that I filled mine up with uh
guacamole
[Laughter]
this is my case at con queso what's it
called con queso salsa con queso which
we had on the on the on the camping trip
we went food shopping you did the
general store and I didn't tell nobody
tell because maybe get some chips
spotted that cost salsa concave at the
end of aisle three yeah you guys were
going at it it was like a halo around
that thing it was right next to the
Buckshot after about 14 white claws man
it was like a crab in that Barrel baby
yeah dollar slice all day dollar slice
all day which they say New York City is
very expensive but you can really eat
cheap around here if you put your mind I
I'm so
trash I love I there's three dollar
slice places that I love the one over
there by New York Comic Club 4th Street
right over there on uh Second Avenue
fourth per se
then you got Percy's which bumped up the
two dollar I mean in the in our early
days in the village in New York
we lived off Percy's dollar slice like
I'm probably lean years not even not
even joking maybe they're both pretty
fat though ten I was tight then 10 or 10
a week probably yeah Percy's we're doing
10 10 10 slices a week at Percy's
they're two bucks now I know God damn
[ __ ] trick is to go heavy with the
parm cheese it's almost like another
slot it's all toppings yeah you really
gotta get it on the freebie when he got
back there any gummy bears Skittles
throw them on top piece of gum something
to get some density do you [ __ ] with the
uh the red pepper flakes it all right
listen I'm a little weird I'm a weird
guy all right this is gnome as a kid did
you go near that [ __ ] not until I was 28
did I touch that [ __ ] no way I don't
know what those I thought they were bugs
there's ants on my side yeah get that
[ __ ] away I don't even like the oregano
all right so I'm a real I'm a germ guy
real picky icky you know what I mean I
won't touch those in public like at the
dollar size spots I don't touch those
was those the dollar slate spots you go
in there's at any given point uh two
crackheads a murderer a homeless guy
there's not enough flavor in them for me
in what and the pepper flakes I don't
really hate you sure I guess you gotta
get good ones fresh ones yeah they
haven't made one of those they're
probably selling the things from the
whole bunches
that's just Loosely it's construction
paper what are you talking about
um a couple staples in there I would
tell you dude it's like [ __ ] three in
the morning I'm walking on walking home
from spots and a couple of Pops this is
a few years ago I stopped into a dollar
slice place and the guy in front of me
Dollar slice places are traditionally
all cash
course cash operation I wouldn't trust
it if I needed a credit off the books so
the guy in front of me orders a dollar
slice of pizza
and the guy he pulls he pulls out a
credit card to buy a dollar slice and
you guys what the [ __ ] it's three
o'clock in the morning you're on [ __ ]
14th Avenue get the [ __ ] out of here pal
so be honest you're here because you ran
out of coke [ __ ] quit trying to stand
on airs and make with the one he turned
around the guy's like guys like yeah
he's like I don't have any cash on me
and the guy's like yeah all right and
then like [ __ ] took the slice and put
it back now in my head I'm going [ __ ]
I'm getting this guy's bogus slice that
he didn't want I'm going I want a new
one you know what I mean I'm not eating
the floor model oh yeah kind of dollars
for 50 cents I'll think about it
he's throwing in Arizona we got a deal
yeah exactly so then the guy turns onto
music so what are we gonna do about this
what do you mean what are we gonna do
about this [ __ ] get out of my
way and let me get two in a diet pep and
I'm out the [ __ ] Dizzle hey I'll tell
you what I'll eat his huh kick rocks
[ __ ]
is probably
unless you find like a dollar Taco spot
but the thing about the dollar store
spot it's a dollar all day every day 24
hours almost that's not the case with
like oh this place has nickel wings or
whatever it's like yeah but that's for
two hours on a Wednesday and you're in
there I always thought that was a scam
too what 25 cent wings nah man shut up
doesn't add up dude the Barber's Hall in
North Philadelphia on Temple's Camp it
was like a little off temples campus it
wasn't it was by no means sanctioned by
the uh by the university and they had
dollar beers
dollar [ __ ] cups like uh Red Cups of
draft beers dollar beers and I believe
it was 10 cent wings
for ten Wings is a dollar a dollar we go
in there that's how the UFC started
right dude we go in with 10 bucks and
[ __ ] walk out Twisted
you'd wake up in the morning how the
[ __ ] did I spend 88 a dollar beer night
yeah your butthole must have been
burning also one of my big claims of
Fame at this it was called Pub web or
something like that it opened like
Midway through my senior or something I
was like late I wasn't there it was open
after I'd already been there it was like
a cool
Paul it was like cool you're like oh
this place is chilling as young like
guys who ran it and everything I thought
you meant you and your crew yeah we were
in there scouting cheese all over your
face no they had dollar beers at this
place on like whatever [ __ ] Tuesday
nights or Wednesday nights and uh
I went up the ones there was like 10 of
us and we were all getting like two
beers or whatever so I like walked up
and I'm like I need 20 like I did the
math like I need 20 Bud Lights or
whatever he's like what so he just
brought a case oh I handed him 25 bucks
he brought a 24 pack over I was like my
man let's go yeah knock a couple bucks
off because they're warm uh-huh that was
uh and then that was another big thing
it was always finding especially in the
city was finding a place where you could
drink for very cheap open bars sure
you know 50 Cent drink nights whatever
the college deals were all right we had
we had Acapulco Pizza that did like
nickel slices Wednesday I'd black out I
swear to you
no dude they had a they would they would
deliver on campus and they had a [ __ ]
it was like a [ __ ] two foot
Cheesesteak for like three cents or
something like that I used to [ __ ]
get a couple of those and [ __ ] go to
town
the big one I think I want to talk about
you struck out
I don't know what that broad deal was
you got pepperoni in your nose
that's when I first put pickles on a
Cheesesteak and it was phenomenal really
ketchup mayo and pickles talk about
experimenting in college
everybody's having threesomes and
[ __ ] turning by and [ __ ] you're over
there you know what give me the honey
mustard you're over there putting
pickles on a sandwich
got real weird in college
I tried a wine pizza for the first time
never looked back
oh did I ever tell you the our
neighborhood uh pizza place not p is
sucked the food sucked but it was
Munchies dude got arrested for [ __ ]
slanging mad weight out of there he got
arrested with like a pipe bomb like
[ __ ] four grand in cash
enough serving like two years I'm taking
a minute here but hold on that somebody
a lot of people were in he would they
would deliver us cigs when we were real
young
you could be like 14 15 you would call
if no one was home like oh yeah we're
getting a large pizza two orders of
cheese fries your cartons of palm homes
and a couple of lucies [ __ ] Shawshank
comes in a towel you bringing that up I
I asked Glassman this but it kind of it
kind of got breezed over a little bit
Toby and I were talking to my beginning
definitely a question that I want to
start asking everybody what was the name
of the pizza place in your hometown and
the Chinese spot
sure I don't think uh yeah we had a
couple training spots we didn't do
Chinese food though at all I don't think
my mom's had anything but Italian
Italian and Thanksgiving dinner that's
all we do lady I told you nine times you
don't do a [ __ ] chicken picata here
but I will tell you this
I don't know if there's one Garden or
something okay that's pretty classy I've
never been in there but we had Lele
okay sounds like a panda right
yeah we also had uh [ __ ] I can't
remember it [ __ ] what was I gonna say I
had something really good oh no he
didn't yes I did yes I did
Chinese spots the pizza rolls they have
pizza egg rolls I can get down with that
dude
don't sleep on those they are [ __ ]
fantastic you want to hear something
real oh oh all right this is this is all
right this is what I wanted to I wanted
to bring this up before uh I want to get
your take on this we're now we're
talking you know we're talking take out
food Italiano last uh I'm down the shore
or whatever last week whatever two weeks
ago we're ordering out from a l p North
Wildwood shout out okay so we went with
the cheese stick with the with the
liquid cheese whiz
it's a good spot chicken cheesesteak
blew my so I go I'm getting a chicken
cheese steak right
my mom and my wife decided to do some
sort of uh I'm out I think I go to the
liquor store I come back and I'm like
hey they're like oh we placed an order
they're gonna make some pasta and then
they're gonna get meatballs from Alp
because I guess they didn't have meat or
whatever so they're gonna like kind of
hodgepodge together a pasta dinner okay
I'm going all right whatever you know
hear what they did was they ordered a
meatball sub and pulled the meatballs
off the sandwich and put them in the
pasta [ __ ] I was like ah I don't know
this is genius or the biggest Dirtbag
move I've ever seen you'd have to you've
never watched your mom scrape meatballs
off a sub no but it's a bad look since
you bring that up oh God uh there was uh
the people were you know to coming to
visit my pop and they were they were
bringing like sandwiches and stuff like
that uh my cousin rolls in with like a
like a hoagie tray from this place up in
Wilkes-Barre if they were [ __ ] uh-huh
but I mean there was just so much of it
sure and my my mom's talking to my my
sister-in-law or something like that
she's like well you know what we could
do we can we we can scrape the meat off
and make a salad with it I'm like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah scraping
the meat although with the meatballs I
would say
in that moment if you took the if you
took the meatballs out chopped it up
real quick into pieces the bread maybe
hit it in the oven for two three minutes
get a little Char on there just toss
they tossed the bread they tossed up
here it's the pricing this was a big
thing they were doing Meatball math when
I got there
because you can get like wait I'm
confused you were at a NLP you got a
chicken cheesesteak they ordered the
food I went to pick it up thinking I'm
getting chicken cheesesteak for me and
they were getting meatballs or they were
getting a meatball they said we ordered
meatballs okay but it was two sandwiches
okay so I call them like lady they got
two where's the spaghetti at they're
making it at home oh my god look they're
mixing sauces
I guess that's insane
I mean I don't think they watch the
meatballs
[Laughter]
that's nuts is mixing tomato sauces that
crazy I think so you've never done that
no
what well maybe it's not that crazy it's
tomato it's not like you're doing
[ __ ] pesto and [ __ ] I don't know
but but pizza place sandwich shop
marinara is so much different than
anything you would get at home that's
weird yeah that's that's weird yeah no
of course that's why I brought it up but
you acted like they killed somebody
by mixing two red sauces together also I
mean this isn't [ __ ] Christmas dinner
they're scraping meatballs off a plate
you think they're getting hemmed up at
the two different red sauces
holy [ __ ] yeah that's pretty trashy
uh-huh I was just like oh man it's
really it's really in me
it's just like the trash it's just you
can't shake it the Aloha end that's what
it was called what my Chinese spot I
just remember it it's a fantastic back
in the day why were all your [ __ ]
places tropical the Acapulco Pizza Shack
the [ __ ]
the come on I want to lay a hot dog
stand hey it's marketing baby I don't
know what to tell you
come down for a good time the Aloha was
a tiki bar what's the name of your
Chinese spot
I believe it was like new ho one or
something all right cut that
gang support for today's episode comes
from True classic the best fitting
t-shirt you're ever gonna see in your
life yeah listen are you a big fat pig
like me and me I think we might be
listen you want to hear how good true
classic is how's that it's all Kippy
Wares in six months let's go kid does
all right it fills you out in the shot
it's good it just fits better it's not
for some skinny mini some little hot
piece of ass running around it's for
some working boys yeah some big thick
boys yeah real [ __ ] fills yeah you
don't look like a fat piece of [ __ ] when
you sit down you go to the pole you
gotta do stretch you don't gotta do that
with the true Classics man we're talking
do yourself a favor start looking like a
gentleman get yourself a couple of true
classic D's uh-huh the first thing
you'll notice is how soft and smooth
they are which as a bigger man I tend to
stay away from the real thin shirts but
the waiter cut the way it fits perfectly
it doesn't make you look all [ __ ]
saggy and baggy uh for you big boys they
have long body options sizes up to 3XL
it's time to learn to dress like a
gentleman upgrade your wardrobe with
true Classics get 25 off true classes
get 25 off at trueclassics.com with code
garbage is 25 off and free shipping on
top of that over a hundred dollars with
the code garbage at trueclassics.com get
yourself looking like a doctor with true
Classics do it baby now a word from our
sponsor better help yeah gang it's tough
to train your brain to get into problem
solving mode it's tough but when you
start to do that it gives you a
different mindset and you see excellent
results and better help can help with
that yeah uh you learn how to find uh
solutions to your own problem there's no
better feeling uh and once you start
doing one it's easy if you're trying to
get back in the dating world trying to
change your job if you're dealing with
the loss of something or whatever
they can help you change your
perspective and solve your problems on
your own uh talk therapy for me has been
fantastic throughout my whole entire
life I've went a bunch of different
times in my life when I was faced when I
was at the bottom of the valley you know
what I mean you got the whole world
pointing their guns against you gotta
fight back baby a therapist can be a
real strong Problem Solver for you 100
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option uh
it's convenient accessible affordable
entirely online it's easy to get into
therapy water baby just jump in you have
to go sit in the uh you know a waiting
room hear somebody else talk the whole
nine yards you do it from the Privacy
you're going home you get matched with
the therapist after filling out a brief
survey and you can switch therapists at
any time when you want to get a when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can be there visit
betterhelp.com garbage today for 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage do it do it and then
uh pizza spot was we had Wolfman Pizza
in North Carolina
it was great but there was hair in every
cross
that guy also owned a car dealership too
yeah I think I told you guys about that
one and then uh come on down to
wolfman's Pizza in Jiffy Lube and then
it's only open when the moon is full I
know they're closed when the moon is
full he's got [ __ ] to do
he can't be making saw when the moon's
full candy making pizza with all those
villagers are chasing your ass down I
gotta go kill some chickens tonight
and then uh hot tomatoes in the town
where I went to high school Williamstown
Massachusetts man hot tomatoes
sounds like a bad company we had um
so I guess when I went to college I came
back for like a year or two there was a
big turn like everything that I had
grown up with a lot of things closed or
changed and new places moved in I hated
that I told you there was this there was
a strip up the street from my from my
mom's at Joe's Pizza had the Big Dipper
and had the Aloha and it was a [ __ ]
Trifecta and it just all went away the
Big Dipper sounds like a war buddy
it's great on a 50 cal blew his head
clear out his ass
also is there any cons is there any
coincidence to all these great
restaurants being opened and you go to
school and you come back and they're all
closed
Hammer dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing sending this
fan [ __ ] away to college you know it's a
waste of goddamn money I was trying to
put a new roof on the house my kid needs
braces
his fan son of a [ __ ] ain't more
goddamn Rocky Road
you like
the idea you packing up your mom's car
to drive to college freshman orientation
and if all the store owners are crying
boarding up their Windows like I'm going
up to Vietnam yeah holy [ __ ]
shout out to the Big Dipper
hard ice cream
real good oh Jesus Christ
um go ahead I apologize now what the
[ __ ] was I saying something about a
shopping center oh like there was
turnover at this point you know like
whatever five six years seven year
whatever it was it opened up two new
places and two different strip malls
like a quarter mile from each other
Pizza Land and then the other one was
pizza world and I'm like what where why
isn't it just Steve's Pizza Joe's Pizza
Iggy's Pizza Pizza I'm trying to get a
beef going yeah Pizza Land made an all
right slice though that's how fat I used
to be I used to go get PNG eat it I get
take out and eat it in the car of the
parking lot wait you would like your mom
would send you out to go pick you up I
would just be like I'm gonna go get two
slices of pizza and just go and get it
and eat it in the parking lot and just
put like that little box in the back
seat and [ __ ] drive around okay I
didn't do that [ __ ] when I was a kid so
you as a kid when I was a kid I wasn't
seven taking the [ __ ] taking my dad's
pickup truck to go hit [ __ ] Pizza
world but we never we never really had
anything the only thing that we would
ever have delivered to our house would
be a pizza but we'd go pick that up we
didn't have [ __ ] delivered to the house
that's not what I said no but I'm just
saying we would do anything though the
only thing delivered we would do would
be and it was
usually no my mom was involved would be
Pizza Hut everything else would you go
pick up unless when I didn't have a car
but I'm saying as a kid I wouldn't go
I would we would I would go somewhere
and eat it I would never go pick up
takeout and bring them back to the house
I don't think
I'd be frowned upon in my house just
yourself you mean yeah so you're telling
me you're at your mom's house hey I'm
gonna go get a couple of slices I'll be
back she might not be there or something
you know what I mean like I don't know
I'm just like
and the pizza wasn't gonna make it back
to the [ __ ] house I tell you that
much I thought you're really making that
though I thought you meant you guys
would place an order for dinner you
would just go eat like my chicken
fingers no you would go pick it up but
you'd get a couple of slices for the
fight oh no no no no no no no I'm just
getting my dude Wawa always ate Wawa in
the parking lot never took it home okay
everything got eaten hot ready like
[ __ ] little C's no Chinese
I don't I honestly don't think my mom's
ever had Chinese food
I swear to God
not an egg roll Kung Pao
General sews nothing uh-uh damn
it's an American right there you know
she's a goddamn Patriot all right
holy [ __ ]
yeah she's a picky eater
and I don't think yeah
should do Indian food
what
I didn't have Indian food until I got
married I don't think
oh no no yeah
she's real straight laced I'm gonna be a
fun patreon goal we take our moms to
some exotic restaurant I just have to I
mean if it's not caraba she ain't going
all right
she loves she loves uh uh uh casual
American casual dining facility
yeah sickness special too yeah he's
always checking how much the niece how
much the wine is too the nisi one
shout out to Cavit Pinot Grigio all
right gang this is a family episode
as you know when you sign up for the old
patreon there get your question right on
here with two experts
being dirt balls
um all right this one's from stump the
Schwab uh garbaggio and I'm on strong
have you ever watched your oven mitt
no and it needs it I use my oven mitt
today and I was like it's brown how do
you wash it you put that I thought I
don't know but I'm saying yeah you
probably throw it in the [ __ ] washer
I didn't think you were allowed to do
that by who the government I thought
what do you mean allowed to do I know
there was some kind of chemicals in
there what like a comforter you can't
wash that
you can wash a comforter can you yeah I
don't think you can wash it down
comforter you ruin it it would all Clump
up I don't like potatoes also but okay
well I mean we're off we're off in a
couple of tangents here that I don't
understand but an oven mitt is not a
down comforter do you think it's spray
treated with something that doesn't burn
yeah I didn't think you were able to
wash those I thought that was just how
it was because ours had like it looked
like a smear a peanut butter probably
[ __ ]
oh man imagine the wipe you could get
with one of them oh man that'll curl
your toes
check the prostate with that thing oh
yeah dude ours was ours was [ __ ]
crusted over you'd catch a fastball
what I got this is I had an issue today
what's the inside of your oven looking
like spotless really yeah oh man I
my [ __ ] was smoking today I caught a
pepperoni in there it looked like it was
from the Jurassic error
I thought a raptor was gonna come get me
like a meltdown a Three Mile Island yeah
no we keep it tight yeah the freezer on
the other hand like the off system are
you kidding me yikes yeah our freezer
our freezer and fridge can get pretty
squirrely yeah my wife's safe she say
I'm saved I'm saving this and I don't
I'm like yeah it just gets
and we don't in New York you don't cut
you don't have like it's not fully
stocked like my refrigerator is never
fully stocked like my mine was growing
up sure you know what I mean like it's
like a little sparse or just like it's
constantly being turned over with new
stuff right
um
so some stuff gets pushed to the back or
whatever and it'll just [ __ ] hang out
yeah it gets dicey back then there's all
yeah well sometimes I got some fish
sticks in the back of my freezer
man yikes
turned into hot dogs
dicey back there uh
all right this one that's a great
question I guess I thought about it
today when I was I mean dude it was like
you throw it out and get a new one yeah
yeah with those kind of things I like to
buy a couple because that's the thing
that like sure you never replace because
you're like oh well I'll get it tomorrow
like so I'll go I'll buy three of them
use one till I [ __ ] it up next one next
one next one sure yeah 100 and now they
have the I think my mom [ __ ] with the
round ones now
they're like round and they have like
rubber on one side it's not like a full
mitt yeah that's what I have I have like
a
Pac-Man yeah a little Pac-Man guy and
it's rubber in the middle yeah those
things are nice real classy we had one
all growing up it was a righty that was
it damn Lefty that was it man uh all
right this one's from uh Liesel ten
dollar homie never had one red my this
isn't even a question it just says my
mom winning a white main coat and then a
Volvo station wagon for being the top
selling Tupperware lady two years in a
row that's clean living right that's
clean living now a mink a white mink
this couldn't have been recent no
there's no way anybody's moving
Tupperware like that Frank Lucas what
are you talking about
[ __ ] rocking a white white mink
Jadakiss yeah Jesus Christ who's she Kid
Rock
I just don't think nobody's buying
Tupperware like that anymore right
Ziploc bags does all that yeah that [ __ ]
back in the 90s in the 80s was nice
though get a nice set broad come in give
my mom a pitch uh we never she told a
kick rock yeah we never
my mom did it Daddy just wanted the free
crumb cake
my mom did it a little bit as uh
uh to like every now and then an aunt
would do something a cousin Avon was a
thing and they would get the girls they
were gonna get the girls together it's
gonna be Patty it's gonna be Carol
they're so you know what so-and-so's
niece is coming in to give up sure and I
think they were just down there getting
all boozed up trashing the husbands yeah
yapping okay I respect a good drunk
[ __ ] traction from time to time
I'll buy some [ __ ]
no I respect that but that that you're
on top of your it's tougher
those things to do what like to do well
with those things I think otherwise what
do you mean to like make money and make
money in them there's an initial push
like you said you gotta get you gotta
really lean on the friends and family
that's the only time we got Cutco knives
from like my mom bought one off my you
know to somebody when in the 80s and
then someone again in 2000 they usually
fizzled out but then to step outside of
that immediate circle and start moving
merch to where you're [ __ ] getting
Furs and [ __ ] cars what was the car
again Volvo station wagon that's an
import
Jesus Christ Volvo's are reliable cars
how many [ __ ] casserole dishes do you
gotta move to get a [ __ ] VW I don't
know a lot though that's wild uh-huh
damn
um this one is trash but also genius all
right it's very rare
that we come across one where I'm like
whoa
this is uh this goes back and forth here
uh all right this one is from Patrick
Bateman
uh haven't had one read yet is it
garbage that my girlfriend keeps chips
and snacks in her entertainment center
cabinets
in the living room yeah
so it's next to the TV where they're
usually consumed I respect it ah I gotta
see what this kitchen looks like but
it's also like it'd be weird if you were
eating in the kitchen and you had to
walk to the family room to get a bag of
chips and then come back that's to me
that's the tough law hold on let me run
to the family you know what I mean
that's weird uh I see pictures sometimes
that people post and they have like uh
they're not it's not a cabinet but it's
just the shit's out it's something like
racks you know what I mean uh-huh yeah
that's a Sam's Club yeah no way get a
door on that thing yeah we kept our
snacks hidden never anything out in the
open maybe a couple of chips some fruit
on the counter otherwise that [ __ ] was
vanished yeah we didn't do it
doc I understand it though that's you
know there was somebody that hit us up
that said when they were doing when they
when they were on the Perka Doodles they
didn't want to go downstairs and get
their their sweet treats so they would
keep that stuff like on the windowsill
really yeah like they're growing up my
buddy his parents in the winter they
kept the ice cream outside
where'd you grow up man our outside
yeah they kept it outside like if it was
like a cold snap they wouldn't put it in
the freezer they would just put it
outside
outside the window I swear to God man I
get a I I you know the [ __ ] cube of
Pepsi sure of course keep that outside
in the garage keep it Frosty that's
taking up good space but the [ __ ] ice
cream
what the [ __ ] you got in the freezer is
it a point of Briars is taking up that's
weird no
I thought it was strange as well do they
have a dog door too yeah they were dog
door people they had a dog door and they
also had a cat door that went down in
the basement which horrified me a cat
door yeah a cat so the cat going out of
the basement that's where she did her
business
it reeked down there it was a tough look
it smelled like kitty litter that's bad
um all right this one's from Nick never
have one red great question here
inspired by my girlfriend since it
happened to her family has anyone in
your family ever won Thanksgiving dinner
from a radio station
[Laughter]
that's bad talking about Frank Lucas
handing out turkeys on 25th Street
throwing out turkeys on Thanksgiving day
baby
we never we were not uh who who's
preparing that
some Engineers ah the intern yeah I
don't want Bubba in the morning [ __ ]
making my pumpkin Wolfman pizza's doing
it
who the savings are
out of control
um
uh well we never did any listen we we
were we treated everything like we were
you know
criminals in a sense of like you never
give your name no one for like we've
lived life off the [ __ ] like we're in
the winter like we were in witsec you
know what I mean it was like you never
signed up for anything because people
are gonna be calling you you never
[ __ ] give out your address all they
want to do now is get your information
I'm not here like all that [ __ ] like we
never to sign up for something free it's
like that's how they get it ain't free
you're giving up something yeah this is
all right on the info so nav net like
I've never anything hey go online and
sign up or do you want to give feedback
nope you figure it out the people that
do my CPAP uh ResMed called me up uh
yesterday and they called me to re-up
like on the supplies like I'm like the
hoses and all that kind of stuff and uh
I've been I've been getting emails about
it but they called me and she's like
okay I just need your your date of birth
and Social Security to to verify I think
no you don't [ __ ] out of security for a
couple of tubes yeah baby I'll get tubes
on the street you called me [ __ ] you
[ __ ] know
immediately [ __ ] give that
information I was like I'll do it online
thank you yeah I have no idea how to do
it they don't even have a website also
spent the whole car ride home
complaining about how CPAP machine isn't
working right yeah yeah exactly
I'm not getting my favorite color [ __ ]
green by the way name of my first pet
that's me to know Maxine I got a drone
over my head in the [ __ ] stinger
missile we didn't we didn't ever we
never trusted any any like anybody
calling
anybody I mean like I used to think we
would go door to door selling like
roofing and siding and windows and
people would be like yeah you can give
me an estimate here's my information my
my parents would they would have ground
me if I ever gave out any sort of
information oh yeah of course people
knocking on people's doors you wouldn't
get [ __ ] halfway up the driveway
Patty would come out from the back can I
help you this is private property
leave the samples and run over
people we're renters but still legally I
know my rights
I haven't paid my mortgage in six years
ah man my my mom was one of the most
warmest and sweet people in the world
but I tell you what you were out you get
on our driveway yeah
he started knocking on that door around
five o'clock when she's got some cuddies
on the stove
can I help you
out the door hey we're just in a
neighborhood going yeah we'll go to the
next door jerk off
we're not interested I was going around
door to door you're knocking hey you
want free window they're going now I go
oh yeah I got it man all right I'll see
you later we're gonna rip you off anyway
keep it moving
Ah that's good stuff okay let's talk
about ladder baby ladder level come on
gang you don't want to leave your family
holding the bag and holding your body in
a wheelbarrow when you check out give
him the final screw job yeah no kidding
couple ious and some late DVDs you want
to make sure that your family's taken
care of and you can do that with ladder
and a little bit thermalife Yeah do
yourself a favor and get over there
ladder is 100 digital no doctors no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
three million in coverage or less just a
few questions about your health and
application easy peasy out the door uh
you just need a few minutes a phone and
a laptop to apply ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved no
waiting going to talk to somebody the
whole nine yards bada bing bada boom you
figure it out no hidden fees you can
cancel any time get a full refund if you
change your mind in first 30 days
because they're good people over there a
ladder get here finally since life
insurance costs more as you age Now's
the Time to cross it off your list so go
to ladderlife.com garbage today to see
if you're instantly approved it's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com slash garbage
ladderlife.com
this one's a little I don't think fall
out uh all right this is from trash
compactor shout out don't think that's
his government name ten dollar homie
never have one red
what was your aim screen name
I know you're not looking at me you
didn't have the [ __ ] out of here yeah 10
years you were probably nah I was I was
I was two in between and my parents
weren't [ __ ] with that that's the
same [ __ ] knocking on the door they used
to send us like CDs or whatever the [ __ ]
they were yeah like uh who was it
thousand free hours AOL yeah whatever
the [ __ ] that was that was that got
burned that didn't even go in the
[ __ ] regular trash she didn't trust
that [ __ ] at all melt it down the lava
liquid [ __ ] uh Mercury make a ring
out of it yeah that was a couple of
bullets kill a werewolf
I wasn't [ __ ] doing it that's what
you were doing in college you're you're
hitting a bird college no no no no no
College not really it was but I remember
you telling me that you'd go out at
night you guys would be drinking then
you'd have to go back to your dorm room
and get on something to see if anybody
messaged you messaged you yes it wasn't
like Facebook or Myspace no Facebook
came out my like got popular my freshman
year of college really yeah that was
like I was like the person it was for
they had just went I mean that's what
probably 15 20 years ago
now ah
2005. yeah damn yeah 17 years old almost
20 years ago yeah Jesus they didn't
um
now you mean I didn't know what it was I
do talk about feeling out of the loop I
showed up to like orientation I was like
are you on Facebook and I'm like what
the [ __ ] are these nerds talking about
on Facebook you still going door I'm
like I'm trying to move a couple of
shingies over here Daddy I remember
being like [ __ ] that dude give me trying
to get laid the old way I'm more of an
analog man knocking knocking on the
girl's doors
[Laughter]
your favorite color purple
you know business cars [ __ ] dollar
Dog Night
I didn't know what it was and I finally
came but we were you were probably uh
Tebow and you were probably aim as well
yeah I'd rather not say my name oh no
I'm sure it was like [ __ ] butthole 69
or something no it was so nerdy uh
Hobbit lovers 664.
Shire [ __ ] one two niner
[Laughter]
what was it dude
Shire [ __ ]
Hobbit lovers you also said Niner which
is a good piece of business uh it was
trogdor 1389.
it's worse strong door
holy [ __ ]
oh man you should have went with Shire
[ __ ]
trog door was that a pig gate what the
[ __ ] is a trog door it was a reference
to an internet cartoon uh oh it should
have been virgin one two three
holy [ __ ] oh my sides hurt
trog doors yeah shout out
homestarrunner.com dude you were
watching internet cartoons
holy [ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] school shooter Sam
over here yeah
my dad
you know what's bad when [ __ ] D is
too mainstream for you hey you gotta go
into the depths of the internet
did anybody know that you'd pop into a
chat room like oh [ __ ] trog door a lot
of shout outs shout out to tea door I
was uh mine was like skateboarding was
uh I had a couple of them obviously but
I think the the double burners
uh do my dirt couple of finstas uh XX
I'm not a poser I swear XXX that was a
big one XX something something what does
that mean XX was just like a you know
just it was like a visually it was like
a thing you would do like a big X small
X your name small X big X
I was never into that uh mine was
Spitfire five four two
let's get fire Wheels five four two the
only numbers you could get because zero
zero one
that's what's the sad part you were the
560 second loser to use that name
say a trogdor was the number one right
there frog door two goddammit Lucy was
original
would that work would you talk to girls
no it was it was like it was just like
your friends it wasn't like you didn't
like meet new people you talked to men
who said
hey I'm looking for truck door
you seem like a real trog door
holy [ __ ] no you would talk to your I
love how you don't know what AOL Instant
Message is I don't you would talk to
your friends it's the little guy the
little yellow guy walking in um you
would just talk to your it was like
texting you know that's all it was it
was from your from your personal
computer yeah yeah okay
[ __ ] Steve Jobs over here from your
personal computer
stinks
it was worse
than I ever could have expected trog
door
um oh Jesus Christ uh but yeah you would
set like an away message like
[ __ ] you know I'm eating chicken
fingers right now
I'll be back here
I'm at Fifth meal
I just pissed my pants man
[ __ ] ah
assist me
[Laughter]
I'm cruising the calf with trog door
Meet Me Online at grubs Tavern
what was the what was the what was the
what was the plot line for trog door of
trog door just give me the elevator
pitch he's the burninator oh God what
does that mean
it's Super Bowl no
oh you didn't have He-Man you [ __ ]
dork
that's
enough
at least that's Hollywood you know what
I'm saying
[Music]
I'm gonna get a lot of love for trogdor
you just watch oh man
um
all right this one's from Kyle have you
ever made friends on vacation
I don't know I'm sure trog door has no
no he did not for sure he couldn't even
make friends online probably
friends on Facebook that's bad or if
you're like on the same boat or whatever
you know if you're on the same thing
we didn't have that but like I remember
people would go we always just went to
the shore that was like our only hey it
was your family like a normal human
being no but people would go on like a
cruise or they're at a you know I had
friends like Mexico were on a cruise and
they would come back like ah this was
Bill's parents or booze and yeah they
throw the kids you know oh you should
Gary was the craziest guy he would do a
half Gainer I would instantly hate those
guys before I met the [ __ ] summer me
yeah when's he coming here all right
anybody can be friends with you on a
[ __ ] boat jerk off tried doing
February in [ __ ] Bucks County
foreign
normally you would just not like the the
the the friend from from the cruise yeah
this guy sounds like a loser sure but
you're so crazy but you were mad at the
at your friend for making new for
bragging that this guy's so cool it's
like oh yeah is he he liked you because
you're [ __ ] on a water slide all
[ __ ] goddamn day
meanwhile I gotta lend you five bucks to
get a [ __ ] chicken sandwich somewhere
you sound like a wife that's getting
cheated on exactly I'm the one doing the
[ __ ] nine to five this guy comes in
[ __ ] for the weekends
holy [ __ ]
oh God that's a great question
no also I feel a lot of a lot of
Honeymooners do that
they go away on a honeymoon and then
because there's all a lot of
Honeymooners that get there on the same
Thursday to Thursday so they see oh you
were just I was thinking kids as an
adult get the [ __ ] they do that a lot
yeah yeah yeah talking to people at the
hotel bar
get the [ __ ] out of here trust that at
all yeah
and stuff
um
your wife's gonna let me slip it in
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up let me enjoy my
muscles are you a lady of the night then
kick rocks all right
hey honey slide me a menu or beat it
um this one's from Andrew have you or
anyone you know played air guitar in
public
air guitar is a tough look
there's the funny like hit like there is
doing it ironically of like you know
whatever but then there's the guitarist
who is like hitting the notes the chords
that's bad you know what I mean you can
like see him like hitting the G minor or
whatever this might be an unpopular
opinion but I thought Guitar Hero was
pretty [ __ ] whack sure I get it rock
band the [ __ ] wackest [ __ ] of all
time I loved it I'm 46. I remember dudes
my age which I don't know how old they
were when they came out I was probably I
was probably my 15 years ago early 20s
probably yeah it was
I knew 30 year old dudes that had that
little [ __ ] drum kit and you go over
their house and be like what do your
wife's definitely cheating on you man
what are you doing you're gonna hear
like a tro door
what are you doing yeah we had it
um friends would have it
also you have to you're it's a little
different I think for like your my nose
is running we hit
you didn't grow up with the escalation
of that necessarily you know what I mean
like
you weren't around you weren't playing
video games when like Xbox hit Xbox 360
PlayStation 3 like no I I remember
playing Medal of Honor on PlayStation
one or two it was probably one that
somebody had given us
yeah that's like so that's probably a
couple steps behind yeah so like but to
like when you're in if you're not in it
and you look and you're like I mean a 30
year old playing is that's a pretty to
have it by themselves without kids it's
a tough look wild but like for us
looking back as a verb through a very
judgmental eye of like I want to [ __ ] on
it but I'm like
it was just the progression of games at
that point you know what I mean like
the guitar came
we played it as like a drunk it'd be
like you'd get all [ __ ] up and then
like be at someone's house
at like midnight [ __ ] playing it
eating Bagel Bites or something
you know what
yeah
um that's funny yeah
yikes you want a Guitar Hero guy trog
door nah not for me
too busy out there slaying puss and
Dragons
casted spells
closing deals all right this one's from
Spencer uh 10 homie here have you or a
loved one ever gone to a restaurant
solely because it was on diners drives
in and Dives that's a great question
yeah yeah for sure we literally Google
it shout out to Reggie Conquest for the
tip and we're on the road I'll just
punch in Diners Drive-Ins and Dives and
Google Maps or wherever yeah yeah where
we went to we went to that [ __ ] Diner
that was on it uh Colorado yeah Denver
oh yeah and it was [ __ ] fantastic you
don't miss say we want about Mr Fieri
and shout out to Shane Torres who's like
changed the
culture on previous gas Shane Torres
who's changed the culture on guy Fiora
he was the first one to be like what are
we doing here this guy is [ __ ] sweet
guy's [ __ ] awesome uh and that clip
went viral and it made me look at him in
a different light and now I look at him
like this guy's [ __ ] awesome I met
him and he was the nicest [ __ ] guy
ever you met Guy Fieri yeah I was
shooting videos what the [ __ ] why didn't
he open with that get him on the shoes
you've never told us that yeah I was
shooting videos for All-Star week geez
I've been treating you like [ __ ] for the
last two years I'm sorry I'm sorry Mr
Trojan yeah yeah I was doing our promo
video for a nightclub so shooting a
video for uh Ludacris was performing so
I shot ludicrous and Guy Fieri showed up
to hang with ludicrous and they're in
the VIP I have I have the footy it's
sick did he bring any sliders or
anything no but I was like dude I love
you and my girlfriend loves your [ __ ]
and he goes oh thank you so much man a
guy yesterday told me he was like my
kids love your [ __ ] and I was like that
makes me feel weird
that makes me feel like a child man he
was awesome dude yeah I'm sure sure man
I'm literally looking at you in a
different light to be honest with you
yeah and if you haven't told us this
before no never and him and ludicrous
were getting [ __ ] up it was sick yeah
what are they gonna do together I mean
those two aren't going to talk about the
[ __ ] Dow Jones you know what I mean
they're [ __ ] they're getting after it
dude they're going over String Theory
you're talking about
um
let's see here all right this is this is
a little bit different this is for Mia
hey boys 10 homie here
what are all the different synonyms and
idioms dirt balls used for pain someone
slash money what I've heard from this
podcast greased up C note a handy
buttered up hit him with a dub break off
a [ __ ] too Hondo sweeten the deal
shekels funds Moolah beans dubsky quiche
quiche and then someone uh someone
commented Jihad a Jihad
Bread's always a good one yo hit me with
break you have any bread on you a couple
of Bones Bones is trashy is it 15 bones
five bones ten bones I like bones bones
is trash
Bread's good
I Feel Like Rappers really influence all
of that too of course like I think they
influence everything yeah for sure
um I was listening to a song the other
day and he was
said he's got he which blew my
perspective because now these old these
young rappers are rap there are hundreds
that they grew up with are blue
yeah not green so they're green like yo
you got any green on it it's hundreds
are blue
so they were the one guy he goes I got
green hundreds in my safe I got old
racks and I was like
this guy's flexing that he's got green
hundreds
you ever see it you ever you ever get a
[ __ ] old like not old old and then
they came out with the big face the big
the [ __ ] the big face the old little
face the 90s [ __ ] 100 font on those
it said 100 in the corner Oh weird it
was definitely like you see it now I
think they're worth more
I'm probably not even in circuit like
105. they're cool greenbacks is pretty
good couple of green couple of
greenbacks
that's me a little gay little butter
uh-huh the butter ghee
you just got like offended that I then I
said that I was shouting you out yeah
thanks that's classic age Fuller that's
mine
get your truck door you never met Guy
Fieri uh
um yeah we should try to compile a list
of because we constantly change it
kashish okay A little bit of cashew
showing them oh I might have to bring
that back I like that I think that was
me shows constantly evolving
maybe it's very intellectual what do you
think about it
um yeah okay sheesh all right this one's
from Ryan crook have you ever gone to a
fast food restaurant to get a free item
because your local sports team achieved
a milestone
no
either have I but uh for a long time
down in uh
uh I think it was Oasis or something the
gentleman's club in Philadelphia they
would do if you went in with your if
like the Flyers won and you or even if
you just went in with your ticket stub
you know you get a free [ __ ] titty
sandwich or something something
he freed me into the dildo show or
something I don't know what they were
doing but you would go and get free
cover or something like that no cover if
you're going with your ticket the only
thing we ever embarked we ever took part
in now Patty's a little different
uh she'll get a freak out Delilah's girl
she'll get a free cup of coffee at Wawa
when they do something Mike I've watched
this is and this isn't silly because
they don't want to I think they don't
want to feel poor
my dad would pay would go no I'll pay
pay for the coffee even on the even on
the free days I like that because I'm
not I think it makes them then like
that's the same thing it makes my
parents and everybody feel poor don't
give me I don't need you to give me
anything lining up for free stuff Patty
doesn't care with that but that good
just with that kind of stuff
um dollar dog night obviously we've
talked about [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] American
at the end of the day kidding me [ __ ]
lining up for that get out of your
diesels go down to the [ __ ] veteran
stadium in droves yeah four or five cars
of Foley's is [ __ ] got our own muscle
we're down for a wedding
that's all I got all right
um this one I don't know if we've ever
talked about this is gonna be I can tell
Foley's Gonna Hate It hated this whole
Trend hated this whole thing
uh it's from Scott B have you ever iced
someone
listen it's a good time I you have to
realize that when you were doing stuff
when this stuff was happening we were at
two different you were sure 32 or
whatever yeah
as a drunk 20 year old that's a good
[ __ ] time you and the boys we [ __ ]
with Bud Ice I remember when that stuff
came out like the 5.0 and all that kind
of stuff what do you think icing is
icing is when you have a
uh Smirnoff Ice oh Smirnoff Ice okay but
you hide it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay I thought anything with a
game you're not involved I thought you
used butt ice this goes back to drugs in
a room drugs in a room yeah drugs
anything that like requires some sort of
fun or attention get out of here you're
out yeah I like the Easter egg hunt when
I was a kid and then there was a couple
it's like an Easter egg huh but you get
[ __ ] up at the end yeah now I wasn't
going for it okay I I totally didn't
expect you to but I like butt ice when
it came out because it [ __ ] you up
stronger of course we weren't playing
games like that we were getting [ __ ]
banged up I mean it's not like you game
where do you put it we're like picking
teams and like you know the signing
captains where do you put it you hide it
you try to make someone look at it
inadvertently mm-hmm
and then give me an example
um like in a cake
maybe we'll break the knife
so if I was like hey my phone's in that
bag can you grab it and you reach in and
there's a [ __ ] smeared off ice in
there a little guy I gotta chug it just
shove it up your hands
in that case I'm in uh yeah you gotta
chug it I think you had to like get on
one knee or something and chug it or
something like that that's cute
um
yeah I don't even know how it started
but it was big for like a month or
something like that yeah it's pretty
whack but we we did it you would hide it
under their chair if you got it under
their chair they had to drink it okay
yeah ours was like I forget I remember I
remember like putting one in someone's
pocket one like their jacket pocket and
you're like go leaving to go to the bar
and they're like oh there was a guy here
[ __ ] whack whatever that's pretty
good yeah
all right it was a hoot
um but we gotta wrap it up this has been
a hot one this has been a some would say
A True True dorktastic one it's been
super fun we spent a good time gang do
us a favor come out there and see us on
a road the tickets are [ __ ] guys I
this is this isn't fake marketing the
shows are selling the [ __ ] out we thank
the [ __ ] Army of garbage for coming
out and supporting us the live shows are
so much [ __ ] fun get those tickies we
want to meet you out on the road we love
you and we'll see you next week